heavy gunfire rings out in burundi's
capital bujumbura forcing people to seek
cover fighting is continuing between
troops loyal to president Pierre
incurrence ISA and soldiers who have
turned against him yesterday an officer
who had been sacked as the country's
intelligence chief declared that he had
taken over president here on currents
iza has been relieved of his duties the
government has been dissolved permanent
secretaries will have minimal duties in
their ministries we demand that all
regional commanders of the military
regional Commissioner's and all
governors work hand in hand with us to
reinforce security
thousands took to the streets in
jubilation on hearing the news that the
president had been removed from power
but they may have celebrated in vain the
president's staff say he is still in
control on currents Issa was in Tanzania
to discuss his country's troubles with
regional leaders at the time of his
alleged aster the presidency has
appealed for calm at least 15 people
have been killed in protests over the
president's bid for a third term